desde la invasión de rusia a ucrania
media net analista de comercio comenzó a
ver las noticias compulsivamente desde
su casa del upper east side en nueva
york como todo el mundo ahí afuera
estábamos viendo la televisión todo el
tiempo sin embargo no era suficiente así
que pensé en que podíamos hacer para
ayudar y resulta que tenía un amigo en
la escuela de negocios que estaba en
terreno y me comunique con él y le dije
qué puedo hacer para ayudar a ayudar el
amigo de hérner está en ucrania y
polonia con el proyecto de ayuda
calvin klein 22 y tras donar dinero la
empresaria sintió que tampoco era
suficiente con su experiencia en el
terreno de la logística para empresas
tomó una decisión llevar suministros
para refugiados desde varsovia la
frontera y también ayudar a la gente a
llegar desde la frontera a varsovia
decidí que iba a ir a ayudar durante un
par de semanas y pregunte a la
asociación que necesitaban y enviaron
una lista la pusimos en amazon y la
compartimos con nuestros amigos más
cercanos muchos de ellos la compartieron
con sus cientos de miles de amigos y
simplemente la respuesta ha sido
abrumadoramente positivos
llevará consigo desde medicamentos para
tratar a los heridos hasta sacos de
dormir facturar a siete maletas una para
ella y seis con suministros para los
refugiados estoy deseando ir se que hay
cierto riesgo pero es un riesgo
calculado así que estoy deseando ir
estará en varsovia hasta el 10 de abril
un lapso de tiempo en el que su
prioridad será únicamente ayudar